hey guys it's been a while it's been a
few days and it's late it's 11 11 p.m.
March seconds Oh tomorrow's my
half-birthday maybe I'll stream for at
least 49 minutes make it until my
half-birthday let's play some chess you
go to quick pairing I could join the
super blitz arena I put a message just
now in my discord telling people to
challenge me but I have no pending
challenges so far yeah let's join this
tournament Eastern super blitz
I don't usually play these but it just
started like 13 minutes ago so maybe the
stream will just be me playing in the
tournaments I can make a run to try and
win it some decently strong players on
top I'll bezerk or I won't beserk too
slow slightly do I want to play let's
play
h4 I'll be aggressive I'm gonna be super
aggressive I'm willing to sack the
exchange wait a minute maybe I shouldn't
take with Queen because then I lose g4
f3 is a strong move
contrary to what that and Feingold might
think because if Bishop takes h5 I have
g4 and now black is gonna have to start
retreating I could even play this b5 and
I can retreat some more looks so nice
it's not midnight yet it's 11:14 p.m.
and hello to people tabby cat meows
criminis GMD illusion okay so I want to
win quickly looking at this pawn this
one's kind of attacked
there's Queen d5 between e2
ee 6 is probably coming let's play
Queenie - I have some idea of like of
here and here
maybe g4g 4 but then 94 and then weird
stuff happens I'm gonna sack this pawn
if Knight takes and I have Rick t1 f6
let's play g4 first this looks so much
fun ok this is a free Bishop now this is
just I mean manslaughter check and mate
that was fun yeah going back I think I
think black should have taken the pawn I
forgot that it like after it takes takes
the Queen probably shouldn't take as g4
hangs so it would have been playable for
black hello to more people
oh there's a don't play f6 emo - well I
played f3 in this game in my opponent
played f6f-3 was strong f6 was probably
dubious just add blue in the chat a lot
of people in the chats
maava dots wait I'm in a tournament I
should go back to the tournament play
some more games high-flyer good evening
I think we're beyond the evening we've I
think we've reached the night stage
okay let's park this time play another
e4 Knight c3 Sicilian don't want a mouse
slip guinea too
the only time I play the bond cloud is
accidental just not that often so we
have some like Grand Prix Kings gambit
hybrid this pawn should be a goner
eventually I want to take with my bishop
whoa g5 okay so let's take and play
Queen h5 check how do I break through
like the King has some shield I don't
have much time Queen f7 doesn't do much
maybe g3 I just want to get the rook and
the bishop into play if takes I probably
start with rook out seven and then
Bishop takes g5 no matter what lack does
and then the other can come in and all
the pieces are joining the party a six
whether random move what is a six such a
deep idea let's do this probably because
this is weak and the knight can't move
because the Knights pinned so the bishop
can't defend if 'if I've I probably just
take it I do have tea I have my gift
look at my beautiful gifts teapot I've
already had like a few cups of tea what
do I do here want to plunder anything
maybe Queen c5 like the migration has
begun King h1 King safety first
weights I'm sacking a rook I'd better be
mating somehow oh if Queen takes f7 I
have made into rook takes c6 now I'm
threatening made in one okay that was
nice just to show people if the Queen
were to take
oh it's made in three it takes or is it
if Knight takes its mates because of
this but there's King g7 but it's also
as it mate where's the mates rook t6t
eight takes takes check chats help me I
don't see the mate if there's not made
in this position something is terribly
wrong with this world there has to be
made here I mean I have a rook a queen
and a bishop I mean we could trade on d8
queen c-17 yeah that's all forcing Queen
be a king G seven I can't access b5 or
c6 and I don't want to use an engine but
I might have to I mean if I saw mating I
could be losing this which is actually
very disturbing
no wait no there's at least perpetual
but still white doesn't want to draw
also a new sub drift Anton thanks for
subbing a six takes away b5 ah that was
why he played a six but he didn't follow
it through correctly okay
so yeah we're cheating and using sock
fish stock fish is perplexed oh it finds
a win only winning move is to take the
pawn ah and this is important to access
b5 because we have to attack along the
light squares Wow yeah stock fish is
good at chess it's the type of move like
if white were to find if it's like a
bullet or blitz game
White's probably using an engine because
it's it feels so obvious to deliver like
some check here even like Queen a7
anyway let's go back to the tournament
so the thing framed correctly I forgot
to check the framing looks ok ok let's
beserk again let's play e5 I'll be
aggressive the tournament leader already
has 20 points but I'm catching up
playing a staffer gambit 'if I've not
too many people play e5 it's an
aggressive move though d4 is probably
the best move white actually might know
what he's doing yeah Queen f3 is a good
move - this is one of the like so-called
refutation
and now I'm actually kind of on my own I
think I can play Knight g5 and there
should be some compensation
[Music]
because I have the bishop hair
I'll Castle queenside hopefully have
some some central pressure you might
play h3 this is actually actually going
to be a challenging game if he does play
h3 I'll just be worse anything better I
could take but then h3 hits me let's
play this I'm hoping he doesn't play h3
and allows h4 Bishop d6 looks nice now
it's about initiative Bishop f4 avoiding
the Queen trade now it's actually
looking very fun back to a comfort zone
territory my mate somehow but the Queen
defends from the rear so I probably
should just take I have two bishops and
the Queen just staring in his face rook
GA coming the G files now half open my
king is pretty safe but I have 33
seconds no increments let's play Rick g8
first it opens up more options if I play
Bishop f3 it's so obvious for him to
defend
maybe now is Bishop e6 ideas to be very
careful let's play this first I wanted
to do this in this but Bishop e6 would
destroy me
expecting Queen f7 and then this
stopping Bishop e6 and threatening made
into essentially rook e1 could be a good
move
there there
[Music]
um that doesn't look like a good move
rookie wanna I think I would have been
in trouble
rook d1 it's just a free rook maybe he
heard me and he just got confused
between e1 and e1 but okay now it's
looking very winning I think 14 seconds
is more than enough to win this is he
gonna pull a Carlson and play this and I
have to take backwards I'm good at
anticipating those moves though always
looking out for tricks okay so I'm in
12th place I have 10 points buzzer King
helped a little bit
hello two more people in the chat
znation chess infinite flash chess
good to see you guys Romina jar is a lot
of returning names all the new names to
young dollar okay let's play a qgd play
Catalan I played this other day in my
match against Pepe this is another line
this is actually still prep usually
white should take I think in this
position I just hold on ooh Texas I'm in
the sack the exchange because this pawn
looks very juicy but how do I attack it
maybe this again I want to migrate my my
army so this side of the board and just
win
ooh I'm threatening this and then this
would be so so dirty oh it's so dirty
such a nice finish 17 moves and I got
the wizarding points I'm in fifth place
Wow though leader this FM it's just
crushing it's more than double the
number of points but there's still an
hour left it's so hard to run out of tea
because I have tea in my cup and I have
tea in my pots a loser
I don't think I've played anyone over
2000 yet
my last opponent was the highest rated
opponent brogan trying to cheer but it
didn't work to try harder my opponent
about to like just forfeits some people
are too afraid I'm in second place I
didn't deserve that I didn't get the
buzzer 'king points but I got the four
point victory every time you watch me
you make tea maybe I should start
selling like are like advocating for
different types of tea whoa so Brogan
tried to cheer a hundred it didn't work
you know he's cheering a thousand and
that works yeah the more you cheer the
more likely it'll work I think that's
the first year of the month thanks
Brogan or is it brogue for now whatever
your name is okay so I'm gonna play
another King's pawn maybe okay maybe not
let's play this line just some boring
Italian but White's committed to
castling and I haven't committed to
castling I'm still gonna Castle and I'll
play this line Knight h5 it's an
aggressive approach the idea is to do
this and this and also maybe this and
the
and as far as I know that's not a good
move because I'm working
at the very least I'm winning the bishop
pair the very most I'm winning f2 and
then discoveries are happening and
basically it's a fork Knights I was
trying hard to not say fork Knight but I
have to say fork Knights I mean look at
this such a nice night ok let's take the
rook and play this now my queen wants to
do stuff take I don't really want to
trade Queens yeah this Bishop is a
sniper let's bring the other bishop into
play I'll start targeting me for my
coming to g3 I have three attackers he
has three defenders I want to add a
fourth attacker that's a good move
actually
let's retreats and okay so now there's
four attackers and four defenders lots
of focus I want to maybe play f5 at some
point let's play a five positional gain
space trade pawns
maybe the bishop should be here and then
here I'll trade darts red bishops I no
longer have my sniper but now I have
these ideas play h6 King h8 let's
improve the Queen and then very soon
play f5 but I just blundered upon but he
didn't see it and now there's pins in
all sorts of directions as I move that
looks like a move can I just take it I
forgot about that move let's pin the
Knights so the pawns pin now I'm
actually threatening to take because
lots of things are pinned to the Queen
that's kind of annoying I don't really
have much time
so let's play g6 I'll win the pond
eventually maybe he's doing a good job
at like defending pretty move that oh
that was a bad tree move I was a really
bad pre move mmm I'm gonna do this and
this maybe it's take this is gonna be
very hard to win with such little time I
do have outside password that's a pre
move this can be a pre move maybe that
don't win my pawn wait if I Queen it
should be easy when I'm about to Queen
okay now keep things on dark squares
dark squares matter and penetrate with
the King come from behind but it doesn't
work as Bishop f3 no I put myself in the
vlog but thankfully I have g4 and he
okay he just blundered now it should be
easy win despite the time situation cuz
checkmate
okay I was getting nervous there I was a
close call
he should've taken with the pawn after
g4 takes I'm almost as lives long I
would have to play this then he moves
the bishop and then I went G for and I'd
still maybe be playing for the win ya
know I'd be playing for a win I don't
know if I would convert but that was a
nice finish some blunders there one
really bad pre move so 24 points leader
has 34 points I've been busy working a
lot of games and keep it up I got tired
I'm drinking like sleepy time tea which
is not good for playing a blitz
tournaments
so the Missouri king will keep me awake
he's busy working - he's playing a
monkey opening the so called orangutan
or the polish I think they call this
orangutan because in actual like
orangutan was given a chessboard and
played b4 this is usually the setup I
like to employ just some nice peace
harmony keep the pin maybe trade off
bishops give me 94 soon d4 looks fragile
let's take first and then I think I can
win d4 by taking everything I actually
have a fork
maybe Knight a three will be the only
way to defend let's do this
attacking the knight he's gonna play
rook t1 I'll move the Queen still
attacking the knight which is tied down
Queens not exactly that happy on our
fates but it looks relatively safe let's
take and this now there's a pin Bishop
takes f7 maybe we'll come then maybe
King takes but then Queen b3 let's do
this so we're just trading whoa he
didn't take my bishop so let's do this
and then I'll just beat up a piece
Queen f4 okay safety first I'm being
extra safe I mean I'm just up a piece
here maybe I can trade stuff well let's
not get mated it's about to play ninety
eight and just lose this is a skewer
trading Queens or winning a free Queen
that's nice
back to tournament
Amaya sub looks like you're Assad if you
have a sub edge you're a thug
like if there's a chess piece next to
your twitch name you're a sub
congratulations all so far of 101 thanks
for subbing I forgot just turn sound
notifications back on but maybe that's a
good thing because I'm not getting as
distracted okay so I'm playing London
move order the idea with this move order
is my rook doesn't get trapped that's
why I played in the early 90 - and this
is actually some theoretical line and
I'm not busy working this game because
I'm playing a decent player and he's
playing like main theory pretty much I
think this should be sevens the main
move here
I had this actually recently in Lisbon
it was an over the board rapid
tournament and I remember looking at the
game afterwards I have some vague memory
of looking at this line but it's been a
while maybe Queen here we can trade
maybe holding on to my pawn doesn't want
to trade so what to do maybe okay he
wants to win this but then I win g7 so
let's play h3 I'm just kind of waiting
to see what he does some more subs
scurrying your cat meerkats aren't
exactly that's scary unless a are armed
and me at thanks for something ok so he
plays 98 let's play let's play a 65 so
what to do I can move my bishop back
anticipating a 6 then move my queen back
anticipating e5 now really what I want I
sac on you fight probably not so I'll
move the Queen back he's gonna play
Bishop e6 soon maybe I should play Queen
d3 too late Queen a5 is interesting
actually it might not be great but I
want to go after c6 like there's some
interesting lines if we trade he plays
Bishop d7 I played rook d7
so he keeps attention good move
mighty for is maybe no it's not playable
or is it takes takes takes know let's
play this someday I want to do this I
could have considered taking and then 94
with ideas of this and this so that's
logical it's take and then play see for
trying to break down the center a little
bit low on time but it could be worse
okay we could trade a lot of stuff good
pressure the bishop let's do that now
the Knights tied down still have some
ideas of this you might take actually
and then I play 94 and it gets very
weird at least he's thinking up on time
I mean this configuration is a little
bit awkward so rook there let's defend
the pawn just keeping tension
maybe my knight wants to maneuver my
Knights not good against these pawns
he's taking way too much time there's no
increment so even if I like blunder I'll
still probably like Fagin but okay let's
not blunder let's play solidly I want to
bring the light to c3 that's a weird
move can start with Knight c3 maybe f4
soon just resigns yeah too slow
okay the game's keep coming I'm feeling
aggressive buzzer Kings probably the
wrong decision but I'll play fast Bishop
e6 I guess it's a move it's kind of
weird-looking though we're trading a lot
of stuff if he plays g6 I play h4 plays
that I just develop maybe I rook lifts
put the rook on e4 just smack in the
center the lights coming in yeah let's
bring it back to e2 maybe I'll play c4
in Queen a one hit the Queen I'll throw
in each three and now Queen a one I have
some battery maybe rookie 5 coming hey
cookie fiber g5 to hit the g7 pawn
i'ma throw in d3 just so my pawn isn't
like hanging in weird vines now I'll do
this now I'm threatening to take on a
six like the combination of my rook it's
such weird coordination but it's so
beautiful
it feels like a blunder but I don't see
how to take advantage of it I guess
three defenders I want to do tactics but
I don't think they quite work again I
want to do tactics but I don't see how
they work so we might trade rooks I
[Music]
punished him let's make things weird we
might just be trading takes takes we're
probably just trading does that make us
traders I think I'm getting the better
of him in the end okay I'll keep the
fork try and make them confused I'll
take one of the rooks and then probably
win II 6 and just be up upon good
position I mean it's slightly easier to
play I guess for both of us maybe maybe
this expand hit the Knights if King f7
Knight g5 on either forza move
forget about Knight of Thor I'm losing a
pawn now that was unnecessary
I mean Knight takes a sneaking F Juan
takes in the knight eh - maybe I win
this pawn back he doesn't have h 5 you
might try and trade rook so I'll
probably avoid it when the pawn he's
gonna play rook I fates and we're all or
nots play e5 or get the e5 square for
the Knights
my pawns are so unusual that was an
interesting move good thing I have c3 he
wants to play what a for all I want to
play King g3 time is almost level if
Knight g5 I have rookie 3 whoa I forget
about that move so I'm down the pawn I
have to flag him I'm down on time maybe
I'll win this pawn okay I have a passed
pawn I'm down how many pawns I don't
have enough time to count that was a
good move
let's do this we're trading pawns or not
okay I win that pawn ok equal pawns it's
still down on time active rook
attack upon this is probably going to be
a draw
yeah GG good game yo yeah I was better
at some points but I was probably worse
at some points I think the draw is a
fair results
is there a teapot emotes I should make
an emo doubt of this be emo worthy
there's a life as good emote that I
attempted to like make tea or make as
like resembling tea I'm gonna be zerk
again wait I'm two points behind also
whoa how many numbers is that 25,000
bits from GM John Davis it's only March
2nd and I don't have much time 25,000
thank you so much Jim John Davis that
name sounds familiar but I feel like
that's a somewhat new name well
congratulations you're now the bit
leader here ok so this is still
preparation but it took me like 25
seconds to play one second for every
thousand bits ok but I'm playing this
line this is actually a nice line the
bishop comes here I have the bishop here
I have the center pons I have castling
rights in Castle either way
wait did he have a message John Davis
oh I've lurked here of bits ochio me in
the chat he Kiyomi
and lots of my YouTube videos thanks so
much
Oh what do I do
wait I I have to stay focused read the
chats in the future
now the positions great it's just time
the rook belongs here
rooks usually belong on the same file as
like major pieces or they just belong on
like open files or half open vials so I
have a plan of this and then this and
then this only one of those moves will
be believable yeah rook h6 is coming
okay
- I have to begin the migration probably
process like the rook comes to h6 pawn
should come to g5 at some points the
Queen will start migrating I don't care
about pawns on the Queen side that's the
problem with these double pawns like
nothing blocks h-file so this is a
monster threat he does have King f1
maybe but I'm going all out
my chief isin move that's also a move
that's actually really annoying let's
play this tempting him to take here then
I'm gonna play this new plan I'm going
up here this pawn I want to sack and
somehow crash through he's defending
let's just throw pieces at him I'm gonna
put the rook on F faith and I'll have
all my pieces directed at the King side
wait it's my move should stop drawing
arrows and start moving let's play this
that's maybe there should be seven
coming I wasted so much time you
ridiculous stuff there okay that's a
free something Brook PA blockades upon
well let's play this and I'm attacking
the pawn here let's move back defending
kind of Queen outside and defending also
accidentally I'll win the oh no I want
works you sudden happens
maybe we'll trade Brooke f7 will come
okay we trade I would miss eight seconds
to convert this okay start pre moving
that's bad treat move let's do that
trying to do something okay checking
from a distance came here I'm I'm up the
exchange well I could have taken the
night ten seconds
hey he flagged I had point six eight
seconds left it's a miracle
Christmas is only what two hundred days
away back to tournament I mean I'm in
second place but I have only one point
separating us I'm playing young dollar
again and it's another sub it's so many
more subs the sub thing keeps breaking
cuz there's so many songs what is this
what is this this is 100 new subs I know
if people saw that but it seemed to be
glitching wait as it are there more
slips okay I it was too much going on
right now did John Davis just gifts I'm
losing count people see this look at
this I've never seen this okay let's
focus on chess efore wait where's a chat
to find the chat where you go look there
it is okay
so I'm giving my opponent time ons
what's going on
let's just keep coming he owe me H is
now a sub I feel like I'm just gonna
flag this game wait let's focus this
might actually be a brilliant game or it
might just be terrible I'm losing two
pieces cuz I lose a bishop and now I'm
losing my Knights and my other okay I'm
have to sack everything and hope it's
meat if he takes this I'm eight let's do
that oh my gosh
that Knight is strong there's more Suggs
iliyan is neck where did he come from
shout out to Illya probably the
strongest player watching I'm about to
flag this is 40 new subs okay I have to
flag this guy despite being down how
many pieces now I have to Brooks it
should be enough right oh my gosh I
should have taken the free rook
okay I think it's almost time to resign
I didn't have ponds that would be still
mates I feel sad for losing that game
but look like he gifted literally
everyone a sub take a look at this new
people see this everyone's now a thug
okay back to tournaments we're gonna win
this we have 34 minutes left 50 some
seconds the leader has 41 points I have
38 points John Davis GM John Davis 59
thank you so much
what is going on d4 okay let's focus
let's preserve and let's play at London
wait at tier 3 those are tier 3 subs can
you give people tier 3 subs ok I'm
playing secret preparation if I can
physically move the mouse secret line
hitting g7 the tier 3 subs are very rare
they're the highest tier they give you
access to they give you access to my
face free material
what are these free things but is it
free there's anything in life for me so
you're gonna take c2 no he doesn't let's
develop and just go after f7
I feel like my quality of chess just
goes down the more subs I have I'm gonna
try and stay focused I want to win
something to start with this and then
he's gonna play c6 I mean do I have to
play Bishop f1 I don't want to play this
[ __ ] f1 let's play Bishop d3 I'll sock
the pawn and then I'll play King f1 and
maybe trade rooks and maybe here and
maybe someday when I've 7 I also bezerk
twitch is not helping my time if there's
any new viewers watching this usually
doesn't happen we're like everyone gets
a son it's like Oprah except cars have
turned into subs it's almost midnight
three more minutes till midnight whoa
what's going on make sure my windows are
working doe-eyed one the castle let's
play h4 it's more aggressive move
wait nilesy first time here and got gift
to the sub nice okay so I'm attacking a
thing and now let's retreat I still want
to target f7 this is also a passed pawn
and when you're so low on time sometimes
the easiest plan is just to push spawns
or push pass pawns also I'm losing a
piece the force coming but do I care
about pieces I care about this upon each
seven this is actually interesting he
takes a piece I have h7 and I have like
whoa I forgot about that move okay let's
attack the Knights I'm attacking
sandesh and he's also getting low on
time whoa it's a 10,000 bits out of
nowhere
wait is that a hundred another hundred
thousand bits okay wait I have to stay
focused I'm not gonna lose two games in
a row
based on distractions
I'll stay focused how many said I can't
count the zeros that seems like more
zeroes and normal I've 13 seconds Queens
almost chat also I hung a queen please
don't take it and then take it yes okay
so multiple people are being generous to
me in different types of ways I want to
do this and then II four and then every
move maybe will be a pre move or not I
mean my hands are shaking and sweating
and they're really cold at the same time
but I'm gonna flag this guy
despite checks all the way by day one so
deep
yes I don't know how I managed to win
that I was losing so badly on time in
position is this a hundred thousand bits
people see this look at that number I
don't even have to show it because it's
on screen and another sub I think the
subs are still being like notified yeah
a hundred thousand bits is and
twenty-five thousand more bits oh my
gosh I don't know what to say
I mean it's midnight it's March 3rd GM
John Davis underscore she I don't know
where the underscore is GM underscore
John Davis okay we're gonna desert this
guy I still want to win the tournament
if I can win the tournament while being
super distracted that would be that
would be a challenge I'm playing over
vs. London what if like John Davis is
just like all the opponents in the
tournaments like conspiring to distract
me so don´t win the tournaments that
would be a pretty massive conspiracy
probably unlikely okay so I'm going for
castling we actually have a reasonable
position except for the fact he's moved
both these pawns and he's not castling
at all so let's try and punish him
maybe maybe f5 and then rook coming
somewhere
what is this let's take and play e5 I
want a fork
I've been forked so many times like in
the last few games I just want to see
what it feels like to be the one
delivering okay so I I'm not working but
I'm doing something I'm skewering those
pawns defended oh he's about to fork me
I want to do something fancy I could
maybe I don't know what to do
subs are still coming I thought you I
thought you gifted everyone a son look
at this there's more subs what is this
100 more subs this is insane so he's
really trying to distract me also I lost
a bishop but that's okay
lost a bishop I have compensation in the
form of sons I was about to play Queen
f4 and hang mates I want to play Queen
up for now let's play after open that
file get to the king this is gonna be a
time scramble Knight G six let's unleash
the rook I'm getting Forks let's take it
oh my gosh let's do this well I do not
want to trade Queens I was a bad life
decision but I'm threatening me then one
is he gonna see it
please don't see it please take g5 yes I
feel bad like I'm more happy and for the
mates but that was no I'm also very
happy for the subs and everything's
going in my favor I'm still one point
behind in the tournaments
man I did not deserve to win the last
two games okay 44 points and that was a
fork in addition to me the fork Knights
so lucky current sub counts were over
400 suggs I mean there have there's been
at least I've lost count I'll go back
and try and see John Davis saying those
have been some of my swindles let's not
forget to loser can move okay deep
breath focus more bits 100 bits from
mama dots securing the third place from
a leader Lord insane GM John Davis has
cheered 150,000 bits it's a big number
also my opponent it's probably just in
awe of the number of bits or no he's I
don't know what he's doing I mean this
is some standard opening usually you
supposed to like play quicker like the
first few moves is it 300 total sub so
far it's insane wait John Davis was
asking for a 40-hour week of chess
lessons I mean if you want I guess I I
have to owe you something I mean I'm
happy to provide like message me I'd be
happy to set something up let's play
Knight d5 what is Queen d6
what is he doing he's gifting me stuff
I don't know what that was just another
generous donation of a queen wait it's
hard to keep up with this like the chat
and the subs I'm still one point behind
in the tournament okay is this guy about
to move
is he gonna I'm I'm being gifted like so
many things okay so he moves I did not
mean to play a French I forgot to
Mazurek to but it's okay I'll play a
French we have an advanced variation I'm
gonna play a line which involves this
and this I'm happy to trade Queens Queen
b3 is slightly unusual let's play 9 h6
I'll be unusual back wait a 40-hour a
week okay I'll have to I'll have to go
back and see but okay the the next 22
minutes I'm focusing on this tournament
because this is still competitive I
don't know what this line is it seems
playable though
let's take a bishop
oh he okay so this is actually very
typical in the French like having the
double H bonds usually does more more
good than harm for black the G files
nice I have a bishop hair it is a closed
position I'm gonna start with h5 I want
to activate this Bishop and maybe put
the roof here and let's complete
developments let's play rotate also I
mentioned this earlier but thanks to
whoever like sent me this it's it's come
in handy I have been using it every day
since I got it
what do I do
it's play key seven one the double hooks
and attack a pawn I'm defending a pawn
here well it's actually quite stable
here because the bishop controls b5 I'm
really struggling with drawing arrows he
wants to win the H pawn maybe at least
one of the H pawns so I still want to
double up the fact that I have my pawn
on h4 discourages any g3 could take I
could take and then play let's start
with rook here I'm actually glad that I
didn't beserk I need to calm down
hey we have another sub subbing on his
own
I see defeat normally like I try and
read off all the subs
okay maybe towards the end
[Music]
okay oh the very least I can do VIP is
this working okay there you go
John Davis has earned VIP status I think
I think I did that correctly okay so i'm
i'm using my double pawns as much as I
can
mmm let's do this I'm I want to play
Bishop e7 never minds he's gonna win
that each pawn hmm let's move back I
want to play f6 typical French move
probably not a good move I just gave him
the e5 square let's play h4 and keen
power let's move back with the bishop am
I getting mated I this is only legal
move please don't make me I mean my King
has no squares but he can't like check
me effectively thankfully I have a pawn
here so he wants to remove the pawn and
then win I could maybe play e5 this
looks very risky but I'm unleashing the
bishop if the light moves like maybe
when g2 but what is my King doing on
that floor
maybe he'll be so confused that he'll
just think for the rest of the game that
would be nice
because it feels it feels so wrong to
have a keen on f4 am I getting maded in
this line hopefully not
chess is a sub thanks for subbing chess
gifted by nicely oh that's so chess comm
twitch channel so the goal is not to get
made in
and eventually went on time it's maybe
control the e-file the only open file
let's do this yes
Oh bishop D ones happening but then I
take off - okay I want a game I'm in
first place 52 points I've lost that one
okay the only one game this tournament
[Music]
there's 17 minutes left when the
tournament ends I'll go to stream labs
and I'll thank everyone especially John
Davis I'm looking Chad is too much Oh
chess is watching chess is in the chats
like actual chess look at this look at
this this is such a rare occurrence look
okay let's play let's play E for let's
buzzer and I lost a chat now now it's
behind my window so I can't physically
look at the chat this game so you guys
can't distract me at least in the chat
let's play a Halloween gambit this is a
bad version of Hall Halloween gambits
but it's still playable I'll play this
and let's play f4 just push pawns want
to go after this hidden Knights okay
this is nice like he did this and this
on both sides and I have pawns pretty
much in his face I want to do this and
maybe d6 with some points and when this
guy
like f7 is so tender it's been
marinating nicely for a while the yeah
that file I can't legally castle but
I'll play trick f1 now I'm threatening
needs this is where the initiative
starts happening if he plays Queen e7 I
mean I want to play d6 but then he wins
a pawn so let's just develop look at the
center it's so beautiful I mean the only
bad thing is that I'm down a piece but I
mean there's full compensation I'm
calculating some funny line castling
queenside here and then I'm taking and
then maybe mating somehow yeah 95 is
mates I've done so much puzzle rush
today like I did I mean what I was doing
earlier I was listening to podcasts and
doing puzzle rush got my high score
yesterday this is a free dish it good
try
that's a free pawn so I'm pretty sure
I've won back the material that I
sacrificed earlier let's take that how
many pawns on my up weight is this this
is may than two that's made into okay
let's find the chats there's a chat GG
back to tournaments Halloween gambits
it's a great opening ooh you know what
else is a great opening the budapest
gambits okay i'm gonna play budapest and
would be very oh I forgot to berserk but
I'm leading the tournaments
I have 57 points the FM was was winning
earlier but he slowed down so anyone
who's watched my YouTube videos on this
opening you'll know very nice idea I
mean I've played this many times before
on stream the brook lifts this is really
the only lifting I've been doing like
most of the year but when people ask me
do I even lift bro I have a clear answer
kuwaiti be subbing thanks Chloe TV okay
so the plan is just to throw pieces at
the kingside like doing a lot of
different things I'm pretty sure like
one of the videos I showed some game
that featured didn't feature it before
but a feature like 94 or something this
is a free pawn I don't even know if I
want to take it like let's start with
this just friend meet if h3 I could even
be crazy enough to do this and then take
and sack to pieces now let's take let's
not go insane because it's just a pawn
and then soon all let's put the bishop
here there's a few potential meetings
where's the H 2 and G 2 so the rook
might come back to g6 and then I'll have
some threats yes herbal tea peppermint
tea it's almost gone okay so Rick g6
would be a blunder what do I do
no that's not a good move
let's keep Queens on the board
I might be running into f4 but then
we'll have some fun maybe f4 Queen g3
takes takes is kind of skewer then I'm
threatening rook takes h3 looks like fun
I could even take on each three right
away okay there's 11 minutes left in
this tournament at some point like if
I'm in clearly and I might just pause
and relax and cool down and see what
just happened the sub note notifications
just keep coming it's crazy look at this
comment if Eric ever drops a I'm Eric
Rosen and you're not our lives will be
completes I'll save that for some day
when people are least expecting it's
Queenie 4 so lining but my Knights kind
of pinned I could take on h3 because
this is kind of pinned what is going on
just a massive clump of pieces in the
center I could take with check yeah a
good thing that's check otherwise I lose
but now I check this is discovered
attack - so now that often you move your
Queens on to unleash a rook but now I'm
just up material okay I have a streak
I'll play maybe I'll play it maybe until
the end
10 more minutes left kind of pinned
actually yeah those pins were more
absolute pins at least one of them was
let's bezerk feeling like I'm I've
reached some kind of zone
move this line this is a fun line a very
dangerous line because the 96 happens
and I'll get the bishop just on a great
square 94 is the best move here and
maybe I can take steak with the Queen
if knight c6 I play Queen h4 trying to
be aggressive now I'm preventing 94
let's do I want to trade Queens probably
not attacking the pawn now I queenside
castle being extra feisty like my king
is a little bit precarious like he has
some c-file stuff but I have stuff of my
own I might sack the exchange soon
unless he does that you just kick just a
light kick I want him to move back and
then what does that move I'm also
playing Knight c3 ok this was about to
get very strange there's my date to or a
knight takes D 1 the good news is my
bishops just a rock and as long as I'm
not getting mated like Black has given
out most of the pieces that could have
participated and now I want to I have
some ideas
east 7 square is a square I mean I'm
expecting this and then there's Queen C
3 threats I maybe play this it's an I
said he's thinking yeah I could move I
wanted to take care of it he takes a
queen back so Bishop e5 let's play
preventing Queen C 3 and also attacking
g7 do I just let's just sacker look I'll
need the rook
I was basically down the rook anyway and
now I think I'm just winning because
after this
how does he defend this yeah that rooks
just kind of stuck whoa it's more bits
how many zeros is that my eyesight's so
bad that like I can't see small things
but that's a big number
whoa it's more bits even again did the
thing break I feel like the thing maybe
broke where you can't like see the it's
not showing up you cheered too many
times or what was that from earlier I
think that was from earlier because all
the sub notifications happen first and
then the bits happens unless I'm just
confused all needs from the slow-motion
replay or is some fast motion we have
would have to speed it up to see okay so
this might be my last game there's six
minutes left in the tournaments so the
game will be guaranteed to finish I'm
playing a 2300 day the player and he's
playing some weird opening
let's just play normal gypsy for I'll
admit I should know more and I do in
this line but I'm pretty sure this is
lying it's been a while since I've
studied this they should see five I
believe is a move f3 and then this
before I move back I think I can castle
I know at some point I should play f6
but I'm not sure like when and where and
how do I take maybe maybe I take and
play off six Queen takes off sick mm-hmm
takes takes yeah let's play that no I
didn't want to play off five it's not
the worst of my lips maybe it is so I
lose a pawn yeah that was another great
pawn to lose
I'm not dead yet I've had so much luck
this tournaments a little bit of
misfortune it's okay let's attack upon I
want to play this but then there's rook
takes before let's play Queen f7 I mean
if I got the bishop to you for it it's
just a rock like it the only way to
remove it is to sack let's play Queen
that fate I want to do this and maybe
this do I know okay so he's sacking or
he sacked I could play c5 keep the
bishop the bishop moves back I attack
the Queen I'm not seeing anything
crystal clear of Queen before also
doesn't seem to accomplish much I'm just
looking for a counter play let's start
with here and then I mean this feels
very wrong it feels like I'm diving into
the ocean for like a quarter but it's a
pawn is he gonna maim me no because the
Queen's tied down to the bishop so let's
take a pawn and maybe I'll take another
comment free bishop
oh he's gonna play off six that's
painful I have to play g6 when we move
and pray that he's not meeting me I
think it's gonna that's very painful all
the pain these pawns
okay well it doesn't matter
I'm leaving the tournaments this guy was
trying to catch up
oh that's the guy who just lost you but
I don't think he's gonna make it
there's three minutes left this is going
to be my last game it depends how shiny
back ordinary quarter is I mean that a
pawn it looks shiny at first until I got
mated okay so we have another London I
think I'll mix it up I'll play Knight c3
he fell into the one trap Knight c3 e
six is like the whole reason why I play
Knight c3
because this is pretty much impossible
to stop any fives the best try but then
I just take it like I've trapped like
relative of a frequent MOT free but two
minor pieces like strong GM's have
fallen into this because it's slightly
unusual like you don't expect the knight
to come to c3 in the London Queen g3
there's Bishop d6 so let's not give
anything for free and my knight will and
that will hop around maybe someday
arrive on a good square some day has
arrived its way be three remove the pawn
and take upon wait a minute
my Queens attacks that was almost a
disaster I almost hung a queen there at
least try and stay focused for the end
of this game now I take a pawn
okay I'm attacking another con the
tournament ends in like a minute so I
would like to win the game and just get
the tournament points I'm on the verge
of meeting actually I would need to get
the rook to d1 or I just haven't
resigned the tournament's over a
pairings are closed success I'm so tired
like I was not expecting it's not
expecting anything that happened like
the last hour well I have the chat open
I don't have stream labs open I feel
like I should have stream labs open and
see like what I missed
open up Chrome hopefully nothing weird
pops up it's just a big window let's go
to Stream labs wait did the person you
just beat subscribe I would be hilarious
if that was a case I have a feeling like
the event thing something is weird is
happening with the event thing like
there's there's such an influx of subs
that pay its confetti yeah GG to
everyone in the tournament 600 players
in this tournament man I'm not taking
challenges right now but I'll leave them
open okay where is what's going on here
yeah the sub notifications just don't
stop chameleon I think these are still
from the gifted like the large
quantity of gifts I'm trying to
reconfigure things also shout out let me
give some shoutouts chess in the chat
and not just like generic just like the
chest twitch channel even in victory
Erik refuses to believe he's getting
this many slugs I'm not refusing to
believe I'm just a little bit shocked
because this usually doesn't happen but
it's like I it's I'm just speechless GM
john davis says very nice first place
and there's some people are saying raid
i don't know if we'll see who's rating
though because I don't think the the
thing is like working why actually
getting a raid he's beginning to yeah I
need to see like I need to like have
some sleep like 100 more subs and
Alexandra botas reading at like the same
exact moment in time what is going on
here like I hope people can see this
just pull up the chat I usually don't
have the chat on stream but like look at
this like I think we just missed the
boat as rain who raided with like a lot
of people
I can't even scroll up like the the
scroll thing isn't working like I've
I've reached the end of the window I
don't have enough like cash in my
browser cache spelled CAC Ichi
thanks Alexandria boat has
who's who has probably gifted a sub just
based on like probability like it keeps
going this just doesn't stop these
reactions okay
I will have to play on chess comm no I
want to I want to do the next arena
kings tournaments actually I just have
to add add it to my schedule
hey current sub count look at this 502
where's 502 according to my pot so many
big numbers okay let me give some thank
yous we refresh stream labs wait did we
hit 10,000 followers I was gonna do like
the celebration tomorrow I think we hit
10,000 follow mmm can't count my
followers before they before they hatch
we don't have 10,000 followers according
to my phone we're 40 followers away from
10,000 this calls fur does this call for
a 24 hour stream probably not because I
want to like keep my health but this
calls for something I just lose a chat
also all let me open up a game so people
have something no I'll have a puzzle
let's open up a puzzle so people have
something to look at I'll see who can
solve the puzzle before me oh that's not
a good sign I hope people see this but
this this is a bad sign this web page is
using significant energy closing it
might improve your responsiveness I'm
pretty sure that's referring to like the
chat or just like the whole stream in
general
Joe bruises Congrats on winning the
turns
thank you Joe groom yeah if you're not
following you should smash that follow
button I usually don't say that
but someone in the chat just said that
yeah using a Mac maybe I have to upgrade
my my laptop after this just to handle
the massive though the bits and subs
okay what do i do do I look at stream
Labs do I look at the chat do I try and
solve the puzzle I feel like no one's
trying to solve the puzzle oh wait one
person who I saw the move saying Knight
g5 wins by g5 actually looks very strong
I feel like I'd probably would have
found that but also oh that's not me
coefficients move backwards Knight g5 I
mean we're threatening this since I saw
it I feel wrong playing it even though I
probably would have found it let's view
the solution oh gee oh wait I'd lose
points cuz I clicked new solution and it
wasn't nice g5 it was Bishop d5 I
thought you in the solution would just
like it's neutral but I guess not GM
been fine gold something thanks GM been
fine gold rawr
I won't rawr as well as GM than fine
gold why is my chief I'm not working Oh
Queen c1 and locks probably at least
drawing if not winning probably winning
cuz Bishop a side happens well that's
embarrassing whoever suggested Knight g5
you just cost me twenty one puzzle
points
what's so sad okay I can't trust
everyone in the chat let's do another
this time I'm not gonna trust the chat
on a work on my own
oh should I go back I should at least
show it there should be five achieves
just for instructional value the idea of
Bishop d5 or there should be five is to
deflect the sky from defending the sky
so after a bishop defy Bishop takes d5
okay this is a bad example because it
just means but let's imagine like Bishop
to g7 I think this is a better example
line then because we've removed the
bishop from controlling this diagonal
especially controlling the potentially
controlling the ggu square then we can
play Knight g5 and that way we're
threatening this and if queen c1 check
it's just a check and white should still
be winning
I assume stockfish confirm yes okay
whoa it's more bits fifty thousand to
make it even no distraction required
feel free to ignore it I can't ignore
fifty thousand bits like I I don't even
know a hundred bits the pop-up oh the
the notification thing is working
fifteen thousand counting the zeros
correctly so John okay G M to use the
full name GM underscore John Davis
underscore 59 has donated a total of two
hundred thousand bits the stream on top
of the hundreds of subs like almost
everyone in the Chad is basically a sub
did we hit 10,000 follows I'm probably
not ending this stream until we hit
10,000 I don't even know how to check
like the live number we're at nine
9-3 been feigl would be so happy with
all those nines look at this nine nine
nine three wait I can't raise a number
it's up there there it is right there
nine nine nine three so we're seven away
there should be a way to get the live
number but I don't know how so
I'll refresh like in a minute or two and
hopefully we'll break it but don't break
don't physically break it just we'll hit
the number current follower count look
at this
nine nine nine nine okay Ben Feingold
has reached his his heights and now
we're probably at 10 K it was my pot
confirm oh you can't spam Mike bought
with followers so it's gonna take a
moment we have 36 of some bits from
Ralph Wiggum we did it
we have 10,000 look at least this chat
10,000 followers so many of ours yeah
shout out to all the viewers like
normally like on a normal night I just
sleep this night I'm gonna stay up for a
little bit I just probably calmed down
maybe even make some more tea like for
those who aren't aware like some
Anonymous like viewer sent me this
teapot it's part of a set a few days ago
and I've gone through like this whole
thing which is at least like three
hundred four cups running down to the
last few sips okay we still have to
solve the next puzzle let's go forward
try and solve a puzzle Croghan 200 more
bits maintaining solid position on the
leaderboard yeah John Davis because
someone was saying you you want lessons
message me like the can message me via
at my website or okay any any medium oh
I'll look for your message maybe
twitches of s just like a twitch whisper
okay let's try and solve a puzzle for
real this rook just looks like it's
hanging but the bishop is also attacked
also White is down by rook and a piece
White's down a lot of material yeah
white side rook in at night okay so we
hit 10,000 also like earlier today I had
30,000 subscribers on YouTube I was
going to do a celebration for that so I
guess it's just one massive celebration
I'll probably put the stream on to
YouTube but I don't know where I'll cut
it I might come it here